it is hard to believe it but one of the
biggest shopping days of the year Black
Friday is right around the corner but it
actually starts now at Chapman
Automotive the sponsors of this segment
Don habrick the president of Nevada
operations is here to tell us more
welcome back Todd good to be back
Mercedes I love when I said wait Black
Friday is starting now and you said why
wait exactly you guys are getting
customers tell us about some of the
deals that you have right now these
Black Friday deals here you don't have
to wait because we're going to do it now
so Rams up to 11 000 off on Rams and you
know it's crazy because a lot of people
don't have the inventory we're fortunate
we do we're passing the deals on zero
percent financing on our Dodge Durangos
for five years free money that's really
unheard of considering just interest
rates and everything right now that is
absolutely incredible yeah and we're
excited that's just the beginning too of
some of the deals that you have there
and you have this beautiful new store
tell us about it where it's at and where
people need to go if they want to take
advantage of some of these 34 70 Boulder
Highway is where our new location is
that is our new Dodge Chrysler Ram store
that opened about three or four months
ago but the other great news is our
exclusive Las Vegas Chapman Jeep store
opens in January and that's come along
it's gonna be so cool Mercedes you wait
where is that going to be that is at
3175 East Sahara so it's only 150 200
yards away but we'll have our two stores
set up right there to service our
customers now some of these Black Friday
deals that you have early are they just
on new cars are they also on used cars
so we have some great specials on our
used cars and as we sell more new cars
we take in more used vehicle trades and
some of these trades are like brand new
five six fifteen thousand miles very
very low miles very well cared for and
then we put them through the Chapman
process before we sell them so there's
great deals on used cars but the
specials that are on new are what the
Black Friday is all about and you made
this comment earlier which I think it's
so wonderful inventory at a lot of
dealerships is still very low but not
you guys you still have have a lot to
choose from we do and you know part of
that is the commitment we've made by
spending and building on those new
dealerships so our manufacturers to
Lantus that makes the Dodge Chrysler
Jeep and RAM product gave us additional
product to support all the expense that
we've had and that helps us just pass
that on to our customers you guys have
been so successful I know your customers
love you so much why do you think your
customers just love you you know we've
developed a family atmosphere people
come in to buy a car it's a very
comfortable environment they know our
our sales representatives they know our
people in service so it's a family
feeling and we've earned their trust and
that's the biggest thing in the Auto
industry is is being trustworthy and
you're not making them wait for a few
weeks to get these deals I love it Dawn
thank you so much get in on the Black
Friday deals Now call Chapman Dodge
Chrysler Jeep Ram at
702-457-1061 or visit lasvegasdodge.com
take advantage of their special offers
no payments until until February of 2023
and 11 000 off new Rams what a deal
Jillian